this morning florida is another step
closer to banning lessons about lgbtq
plus topics in certain grades state
senators passed a controversial
education bill yesterday that forbids
instruction on sexual orientation and
gender identity in kindergarten through
third grade it has led to widespread
protests from critics who have called it
the don't say gay bill manuel bajorkas
has more from northern florida where
governor ron desantis is expected to
sign the bill into law
[Applause]
opposition to the bill grew louder in
recent days with students statewide
protesting and staging school walkouts
many carrying pro-lgbtq plus signs and
chanting the florida senate's only
openly gay member spoke out within the
chamber
i don't think y'all understand how much
courage
it takes for these children to show up
every day
but after hours of debate on the senate
floor tuesday 22 year 17 nays mr
president so the bill passes
lawmakers passed the republican-backed
parental rights and education bill which
would ban instruction on sexual
orientation or gender identity in
kindergarten to third grade parents
could also sue school districts for
violations
republican state representative joe
harding sponsored the house version of
the bill
we want focus to be on those basic
fundamental things the reading the
writing the math discussions are going
to come up we can't ban a conversation
we can't ban a discussion it's not what
we're doing critics disagree saying the
threat of lawsuits will have a chilling
effect on those discussions and the
bill's broad language could apply to any
grade
which is part of the concern parents
like todd and jeff delmay have for their
12-year-old son blake how do you see it
affecting a child like blake i can
visualize the interactions that he may
be having in class kids especially when
they're young they may kind of blurt
things out or in front of the whole
class and the teacher has to or should
respond to that to allow this
legislation to take us back and to not
only return us to a place where
we were silent on these issues
but where it's being enforced by a
penalty
it's a frightening time
nationwide there are 18 similar bills
moving through the legislatures of nine
states the u.s secretary of education
called florida's bill hateful and hinted
at possible legal wrangling if federally
funded schools are found to be in
violation of the nation's civil rights
laws nate
manny thank you